You
Hello
Bonjour
How are you
How are y'all doing today?
It's me baby
and I'm return time
I think it's only fair I dress as a as bb for for faith I don't go back of my little shawl on though
I'm just too lazy um wow I haven't seen you guys in quite a bit it's been a moment um I hope you guys
are doing well what the heck was that wheeze I just did um how I accidentally just like poke
myself in the eye trying to fix my glasses you know just just pawn pawn girl things um
my life revolves around shimmy streams and I'm here for it make sure you go outside and touch press
honestly I won't lie to you I think the best thing for me these past couple days has been going to
my mom's house and watering her plants and just getting outside um because I really have been
mostly inside um a lot of the the year and even at my job like there wasn't any windows
well okay hi boomi there wasn't any windows at my job so I couldn't see out toward
I was you know I was sequestered away from the sunlight um because they're taking boomi for walks
yeah so I think I actually just like might like ask my mom if um if I can just like come over in
the morning and hang out with her sometimes I am gonna see her what's today Thursday I'm gonna see
her um probably tomorrow and hang out my parents Friday and Saturday just because I told my mama
how I've been feeling because I've been sick and I've been kind of just like um just getting bummed
out from stuff so I am you know revitalizing my energy by hanging out with my parents yeah I've
been really uh meeting it up I was I've got my house is so messy it's really bad like I
I need to sweep I need to clean there's food I have to do the dishes there's so much crap everywhere
but I'm secretly super happy because I finally managed to get my whiteboard up because I kept
falling down and then I got uh command strips that support 15 pounds and now it finally works um
um yeah I definitely I'm like I'm my model is like going probably freezing because I'm looking
behind me at my house and I'm just disappointed in myself my clothes are everywhere I'm just
throwing things everywhere and then I I always say like your living space is a usually reflection
of your mental and my mental must be very messy right now and cluttered um I got fia next to me
she's big chilling hi she's big chilling she's big chilling oh she's trying to come and lick me
you got I got her new litter and it like I don't think I like it they didn't have the litter I wanted
I got like pretty litter um but I don't I hope it just doesn't stick to her when she's the bathroom
that's why I usually get paper litter for her um
I remember her hair we had this cat hair everywhere it's probably the reason why I've been sick is
because like there's dust and so and there's just like trash like there's still there's a crap on my
desk and I'm just like I'm gonna go crazy so I like my new to clean um can you have a hug of
course you can he's a hug um do you ever live like this in fact Batman and sonic posters
in your office impressive um something sounds like you gave some of the plants and the plants gave
something back 100 um oh I actually asked my mom what those plants were uh the flowers that I took
it was a I'll tell you right now that's funny because um Dempo actually guessed one of them
uh it was verbena which was the white one and then there was this type of sunflower
and then the rose of Sharon was the yellow rose I could I like I had a feeling and then of course
Adalia was the pink one um I planted I planted that one I I made that flower my mom just keeps
it alive um but I planted all the dahlias and my mom's garden which was a pretty cool to see them live
um because my mom has a really good green thumb and I do not I kill all the plants I touch besides
the monstera it's actually doing okay I need to get like stakes for it though because it it's so big
it needs something to hold itself up I need to get like twine and then I have another philodendron
except it's just a regular philodendron above my right next to my desk probably have to water it soon
yeah definitely have to water it um wait do I have any water in this usually I was dumping old water
no I can't I'm not putting that that's I still have the dry I still have the dry ice water on my
desk that's that's how messy these stuff is um but yeah and then I feel I just I finally
I did like my schedule like two weeks out and I have it all up on the board
and then I put it on our schedule thingy and I'm just trying to be more organized um I'm probably
also gonna start taking another day off because I realize you know my normal day off is Sunday
and everything's closed on Sunday so I'm gonna probably do like Thursdays moving forward um
I'll also like take off to like get stuff done record um like do like doctor's appointments and
stuff um just so I feel like I think I need to pace myself uh although me doing two streams a day
I just can't um get enough of you guys I suppose um but yeah so but like don't think I'm gonna like
like two streams a day wouldn't happen like I I've really just been doing gorillas for the um
for Elden Ring the DLC as I want to and when I'm in the mood for playing Elden Ring then I'll just
do a double stream but don't think like that like gorillas are going to like that like two streams
a day are going to be a regular thing I can't handle that I'd rather do an endurance stream um
because I realized I actually get more tired starting a stream than ending a stream um rather
than just continuing to stream I know it's very it's very interesting um but yeah I need a week
day off to get things done um I'm also cleaning up my marshmallow I just cleaned up a lot of stuff
um it's still still kind of being cleaned up um but I I'm open to marshmallows again
there is like a lot of stuff in there um positive and negative but um mostly positive but I just
wanted to if I didn't respond I'm sorry but you know I saw it um but there was a like 600
maros in there so I I just needed to clear them out it was like really like I was kind of like
getting super like um like I like would freeze every time like and then just like that I was
overwhelmed with the thought of like answering all of them and like kind of going through so I just
I wanted to clean it up a little bit um so I had management go through it and clean it up for me
which I appreciate um don't worry they didn't like look at anything they just like ran something to
remove stuff which is I thought was pretty neat um but yeah uh so then you guys can um just because
since I'm not looking at my um alt account or I'm not obsessively tweeting every hour of the day
and I'm not looking at uh the threads I'm just um I haven't looked at them since I said I wouldn't
so you guys can like just say hi uh or like um leave me a message or leave some advice and
all that stuff but still you know feel better about you know being anonymous and everything um
but yeah I'm again I'm probably I might not respond to everything but I will try to read every
marshmallow they can just get really overwhelming sometimes with the volume that gets sent in which
I never really anticipated before but I'm very um thankful you guys you know want to talk to me
don't think I don't want to talk to you it's mostly just like um uh it's it's not you it's me
so I might just get overwhelmed I may not respond right away but I'll try to respond to as many as
I can but please understand it's a little bit difficult um please don't pressure me or get
mad if I can't respond as much as I did in the very beginning um yeah it's like it was like a
it was a lot um but yeah so today has been a good day I'm really glad that you guys enjoyed the ASMR
I was listening to it back um I was listening to it back um ASMR and it sounded really really good
so I'm really really happy so um I changed I was gonna do a Gunpla members Monday next week but
I'm gonna make it a members ASMR and um and yeah and so we can we can we can do our own little ASMR
and it'll be again when I I'm moving forward when I do like obviously when I do like Patreon
audios or membership um members ASMR it will be in character as like um dummy mommy stuff just so
you know you guys like you signed up you started watching me for a reason and I I identify with
that reason heavily I I I fucked with it heavy um so I want to give you what you want um and then
I'll plan I I still haven't planned um never mind I'm not gonna finish that sentence hey
um but I still I just I reached out to someone for a collab that I have to add on to my schedule
um gotta figure out what to play um I also have oh wait did I make it a script writing
did I make it hold on I can't remember if I did it and members ASMR or script writing ASMR I can
always just make it an ASMR and a script writing ASMR um uh you know what I mean um let me see
nope I accidentally clicked on strongy's thingy
oh strongy's right next to me okay yeah it's a spicy script writing with hair with harem next
week for the members and then like black man through a kong and then do do do do
I'm gonna do a collab with strongy and then I have I took Thursday off and then I have ASMR
Friday and then I have a double booked on Saturday for collabs I did not realize in
as there is also a double booked and she's like I had a feeling you forgot I'm like why didn't you
tell me it was too she's like I don't know I'm like yes sir you know how forgetful I am
I need assistance um but it's okay so next week will be uh members script writing I apologize
and then the week after that is the one that's the members ASMR um but yeah I I still haven't
started in the scripts yet I need to get on that um so that's why I also took Thursday off so I can
do some script writing and all that jazz um just so I can really just lock in and focus
also clean the house and stuff um yeah I'm trying to find you know stream uh streaming is now my
full-time job which is awesome it's my dream come true and I'm trying to find a good healthy routine
that um helps my mental but also keeps me like connected with you guys because I care about
you guys immensely um the monkey game has been boteth the belt what belt why would I have a bell
your angry stepmom beats you ASMR oh actually wait that's not bad um but yeah I'm just trying to find
you know a healthy balance and stuff um yeah I don't think you guys are doing anything wrong
or like that like honestly I could not be more happier with all of you you guys are wonderful
you guys keep me sane I almost forgot to go water my mom's plants because I wasn't looking
at my other account for you guys to remind me and I was like wait I'm missing something and that's
why I but I said I moved the the lunch date to 130 and then back to one because I thought I was
gonna be later than I was but it was fine let's take off my little flip flop hello I'm doing fine
um as you can see I have the heart rate up it's right above my head I might put it in a different
spot I don't know maybe I'll just like it looks like I'm wearing glasses that actually doesn't
look that bad little tiny glasses I don't know is that was there fine maybe we'll figure it out I
just wanted to be visible little glasses wait can I give myself little glasses but I really
enjoyed doing the ASMR today honestly I won't lie to you I I never really did ASMR that much
because I was so self-conscious of my um sound in my audio settings and so it was kind of difficult
for me um not that I didn't enjoy doing ASMR it it's just that it was like I was so it was so
self-conscious oh guys come on that looks pretty damn good I wish I had like little little bifocals
I should have a monocle
but um
but yeah perfect granny sheebie I it's funny when I used to I used to have like more rectangular
framed glasses and I used to always look over them at my parents and my parents would make fun of me
and say it's like an old woman now I have really big framed glasses um I think they look better on
my face anyways and uh now I can't look over my glasses and look like a grandma wait is there
another set of wait where are the I had other glasses oh here they are
there we go these are oh hell hell oh hell hell
you look like they're sticking into my eye
oh my god I do look like a grandma
it's not a hijab what are you talking about um let me fix this actually
this is kind of not big as I want and it kind of is rotated to the side
there we go I think
well I think it's stuck to my booba but that that'll just have to be how it is um
hello hubby I'm a sexy anime girl I do look like a grandmother so bad so I'm a gilf now everybody
I guess I am really a 50 56 year old okay no that wiggling is gonna bother me um
stick to my hair why is this sticking to my boob
I don't even know what it's doing whatever whatever man whatever
gilf nun gives you ruler
hashibi that's funny I know like it literally has jingles
it's sticking to my chest um but yeah do you guys have any comments about like what I was just
talking about because you guys you know I value your opinions um so so please please let me know
um back to what I was saying about me with the day off and me with the um with the maros
and just limiting like I'm gonna eventually go back to my alt obviously but just limiting my
tweeting more just because I realized I can get really caught up in stuff and just yap yap
yap yap yap and talk so I just want to uh I want to limit the talking to mostly here
and just chatting verbally with you you know you know I'm gonna sip some water while you type holy
crap my streamer you sound like bugs bunny
yeah and then we can just party hardy on fridays and saturdays
you night shifts on mondays a chance to miss the member stream oh i'm sorry
thank god for vods I know strani does more member streams but I'll be honest with you
I I don't really have a lot of ideas for member streams and I again uh doubling up on streams
um can be a little bit difficult I try I try when I can but um I don't know if I'd be able to do
double up on streams um like strani does for members I would love to match like match her freak
her energy but she's a different breed of streamer I'm pretty close but I'm not there
are we still gonna do gunpla yeah eventually I might do that for like an actual hand cam stream
um could we at least get a good more good I thought this is a good monging good monging
minging uh street tweet on my main uh I'll uh I'd probably save that for my all guys I'm not
canceling or deleting my all um is this that and I'm gonna still tweet on my all I'm just not
gonna spam it with every waking thought that I have like I normally do so I will yeah I'll definitely
I'll give you guys good morning and good night messages as much as like unless I pass out which
is more often than not I pass out um but yeah since morows are open I'm gonna send you on the
nature walk I took oh nice you saw some cliffs oh jump off no no I love I love looking at
nature's stuff please please do uh oh my god she hates us yes and yeah uh totally totally
me trying to be the best streamer and find the balance is me you and particular I'm kidding
kidding don't hesitate to just do a yab stream if you don't have anything in particular wait what
oh yeah he meant to say yeah but you said yeah get all my yabs out of my system and just do as
many as possible oh I get you but just know I go here because I eat your birthday and
fuck feeling pissed off cat pics yeah of course
hello I always appreciate the lurkers no don't throw yourself off the cliff no
I mean that was I don't even know what my yab would be guys
oh would my yab be predictor right now what's my yab
be brutally honest I want to know what you're thinking
whoops gonna blame it on that phone posting yeah yeah posting sorry
yab is telling that's not a yab that's just me being edgy just kidding I'm not being edgy at all
good luck thank you try my best out here no I'm not saying it forgive me
going off on my lv doopers again yeah no I'm just not even trying to mention them
ask ham stream has I'm or I've already done that
the last thing I want is to manufacture am over the haters understand yeah but like
like we're meming right now
I'm asking for memes I'm not asking you to like freaking doom
my yab is she's be like oh her yab is that she kills herself on stream in minecraft
finally singing bonfire
I should do that as a stream how would all of my gen mates and myself yab and then like
yab scrawny is exposed for not having an ass
I would say a media is exposed for having big tatas but we already know that she does
um yab I see secretly isn't russian
but you already did sing bonfire I did I I can remember
can start a stream and yab about anything like I see and yeah why are you guys keep saying
yeah but instead of yab I'm like wait what did I see do what did she yab about okay guys I think
I might have to take off this freaking headdress thing is pissing me off
go away now I'm just a grandmother with big booba hello dairy
yab she be was white that already happened
did
I see is it russian I don't remember where I I don't remember where I see is from
I forget where her accent is from she says she speaks russian so I'm just assuming she has a russian accent
I thought yab actually meant something so I'll tell you if you don't know what a yab is
it's just like an off-sing term in a v2 bring community means it means just like you kind of
you just mess up and you just you essentially just yeah kind of just like make a really big
mistake I usually pisses off a lot of people um example my yab being accidentally pissing officer
community um but yeah catholic yab incoming what is for the experts what's an expert
I don't know yeah I don't know oh wait hold on I need to check something really quick
I asked somebody to make some art for me so I'm just checking on them
Mari changed her PNG again so I have to change what
so I have to change my thumbnail yab I yes exactly I couldn't remember what the word was thank you
I call experts the gill flowers oh they wanted to send out nobody wanted to silence me um my
favorite yab was when you almost got yourself cancelled by playing around models see that's a
yab and precise you guys are learning really fast you see what Mari tweeted yes I did see what Mari
tweeted I don't know I don't know why that's a big deal um I like I like how she really tweets
afterwards I can say it and I'm like wow me and her are the same um men who know how to deal with
the partner oh cool thank you my way does there more I have now I just want to go look at her
Twitter hold on let me just take a peek here let's just take a peek at Mari's Twitter
that that that oh also I have I'm logged out of the alt account on my phone not my computer so
I can do that anytime so I'm limiting to myself to when I get on the computer I can take a peek
at it but um I usually I mostly tweet from my um
from sorry I'm looking at what Rurune freaking quote tweeted what is that um
I forget what I was saying this is throw me off so bad
they're doing flips how does that not break their arms
why can't I stop watching it okay sorry uh okay let's go to Mari
she's at school right now
the fashion roblox I had to introduce myself in class and I threw up but held it in so it
all came out of my nose nice why does this have almost 10k views
I cannot with her she is she's a goof she is truly a goof
I'm a champ yeah that's not even a yab though I said I'm a pokemon smash or pass people got mad
because I said I would smash my champ and they were threatened because they compared him to a
black man and I was so confused by that oh so there's an audio that goes with the picture
Amy posted right there was um I don't know what happened to it I don't know if she um I don't
know if she's gonna post it or anything I have to ask her about it um because I saw the the image
and I was like oh oh which is the audio so I went on Amy's account and see if she posted the audio
but uh it looks like she didn't do it um I was based off of uh because I know a lot of people liked
um
I'm like should I use code names or should I just use their real name I really don't care
uh Rifu and Kiki's audio they made together um and so that's um what me and Amy recorded something
similar um and uh and that's where and that's when I've actually talked about it before it was
like a couple weeks ago that me and Amy were working on something in call and we figured out we could
record um and so like user microphones and discord as we use them for audacity or whatever I don't
know what recording thing she uses I just use audacity and so um and so I got to hear uh Amy
live recording and I'm like whoa is this what your patreon is like I understand now
um but yeah I don't know I can just ask her uh in fact I love the art it was so good I was like
I like me some Buddha uh let me message her right now
hi I have people asking in my chat on stream
if the if the audio is going up with the picture you do
boop boop boop boop boop boop yeah you guys would like it a lot
at least I hope you would I hope you just remember you're not allowed to what
what why are you guys sweating what's happening why are you guys bonking
I'm confused members are banned oh oh yeah
yo yeah so you would listen to it and you would just suck it would just suck for you
couldn't even do anything whoa I don't because it's not me
are you kidding me right now you wouldn't because it's not you do a lot of you share that sentiment
would you would you want the audio or would you not
it's a joke oh okay I got really scared for a second I'm like oh because I don't want to
I self-insert as in as you should as you should
maybe she's no I we all know I have a terrible memory and I am forgetful we already established
this earlier um but yeah okay I just want to make sure because I wouldn't want anyone to be
bothered by that because I know some people didn't like some of the collab audios um
strong you was telling us and stuff uh because they it's it's harder for like self-insert and
stuff so I would I would hope that you guys well the forgetting emo is literally the like dial up
the dial up wow uh the like that's how that's the sound I hear the dial up sound yeah that one
the loading that I hear dial up when I see that
um the reaction on twitter was positive yeah I like collab audios but you know people don't like
like if the majority don't like them then of course yeah somebody mentioned um and they had a really
good point that uh it was because it like they would prefer like four audios each month for
patreon of the single talent and then meet like then a bonus one because they they don't want
them to take up a spot and I was like okay don't change I get that um I think most you would
use them out though yeah I feel like it might be a little split
collab audios on patreon are not the same thing as free stuff on twitter yeah that's a good point
as well if you pay for four of the talent then I like it like that's why I'm like okay I understand
and then if you get like a bonus audio and it's a collab then that's pretty neat so
maybe maybe we could still do uh collab audio so we'll just have them as a little bonus um
um yeah because I know like for my donathan I have some collab audio things just like Azura did um
so I hope that you guys would like them because they wanted to be worth your while of course
fun fact she beat the loading symbols called a what ankyl me
yeah I yeah yeah
I was going to use your subscriber both patreon and collab audio meaning like seven hours one
so yeah yeah see like I get that yeah but like I think I think that's already been kind of like
sorted out so like I could just bring up to strongy like hey maybe be a good idea to add a bonus
audio if like the girls are up to it um every once in a while and I think I think the girls would be
down um just so yeah self-insert is in me so she beat
oh yeah I know the art is really good I was like hey oh um that's so funny I didn't know that um
but yeah I still need to when you get those scripts done I need to record them and so I can send
them off to the audio editor I still got plenty of time it's only the fifth but like I like to
do stuff early so I don't have to worry about it later because like um like I did my audios later
um last month and I'm not I wasn't stressed out but I'm like I prefer to do the ASAP um and then
I still have I'm getting my scripts written for November and December they're still in the writing
phases and then I'll bang those out real quick to be fair the azure collab audio is about twice
as long as your tip of audio so I wouldn't feel like I got one fewer audio for what I paid true
true oh wow fia is dreaming hardcore she's twitching it's very funny um but yeah
sorry I'm doing a lot of zatsu because um I just want to make sure you guys are good
I keep forgetting well none of the chat freaking works it doesn't work maybe I'll add a chat window
instead what if I do this I might have to start popping out the chat because since it keeps freezing
and then putting the chat up just so vaude watchers I'm so sorry vaude watchers I know it's
probably a lot easier for you to follow when you can see what the chat is saying um so I apologize for
that
where is the where is the chat window
I don't see it
is it invisible
where's the chat window this is not there
if I I don't want to freeze again that weird glitch okay
so
youtube has chat replay yeah but sometimes it doesn't work
wait I need to make the chat window a little bit
wait why isn't it letting me change the uh oh whatever it's fine
it's just gonna be one line
yeah chat replay disappears if I edit the vaude not that I edit the vaude a lot
you guys are gonna be up there doing whatever I don't know or I can have you over my booba
okay that's funny
yeah I haven't really added any vaudes I'll I'll usually just freaking nuke them to hell um
but now I'm trying to minimize me doing that as well so that's why I'm trying to behave
I just I want to be I am cute and I am funny and I am say so and I am so sweet and already
is going to have me delete vaudes I'm going to be fine it's not going to be good
I am sweet I am say so I am professional I am very good I am not a vtuber I am say so vtuber
I am very normal so if you want to be my friend
if you want to watch my streams you have nothing to worry about
yes cute and funny and say so and dominant
she lied as easily as she breathed
I
get raided who's raiding
oh they're gonna see me in my granny outfit
hello there dearies welcome in
why am I Glex because I'm an old woman
come in deary strawney why don't you give grandma she be a kiss
hi well I hope you guys yeah I'm the ultimate hag I am the hag two out hag all of the hags
enter my deo I did not see that in me I'm sorry
if you're still up for uploading it you could probably edit together RN if you're available
yes ma'am I don't know why I'm saying yes I'm typing yes ma'am when you're gonna hear
when you're gonna hear it you like my wet kisses that's me eating your face
also I love you sorry
I
yippie okay then that the boys asking you shall receive the fun audio is coming
what's with the bondage bunny today
you're going to talk to your grandmother like that I'll beat you grab me a switch from the garden
another three decades has passed I'm here now 86 year old sheebie truly hag maxing today
of course yeah Emmy Emmy worked hard literally she's just like give me your voice so Emmy is
doing all the editing she's doing a great job I just need to upload because she made two there's
two parts my part and then her part so everybody when that goes out make sure you give lots of
love to Emmy because she did a great job editing she scripted it and as editing it I just lended
my voice she's very talented like that switch no switch do you notice switches it's like a long
stick and I'm gonna beat you with it your name is making me want gummy bears I wish I got gummy
bears when I went to the store instead of just Reese's now I want sweet stuff
the Nintendo switch I just beat you with a switch
you think pin pals have like one straight one like we have one one
one
no
that one straight pin pal what
what
Emmy
wheezing
nothing Emmy nothing the carry on carry on my sweet child carry on my my sweet little sister
spicy gummy bears in a pack what Emmy made them this way
the temptation to do the same is strong but I will I will refrain
I just feminized my fan base
I want to dress you up and make you the little my little personal dollies
would that be so bad come on I'm gonna do your nails for the next ASMR so every every ASMR just
me me secretly feminizing you the next one will be going shopping with your older sister
I'm glad I'm a reefing
not for long you'll be both soon enough soon enough you'll be walking around
throwing up and wearing a G string and a bra for a little eight cups
dressed to impress streamstripe that oh that'll be a good idea I'm a hairy bearded man that won't
stop anything don't stop me a hairy bearded man can still wear a dress don't limit yourself harlot
a cup I'm going down that got me
yeah I can braid the beard
I won't subject you to high heels unless you want high heels
if you get if you want high heels I'll make you wear pleasers if you don't know what that is google it
actually discover what they were recently myself when I was looking for shoes
show me the dress then we'll talk high heels take skill I've been wearing high heels since I was like
literally a toddler or like heels for toddlers because um yes that's how you spell it pleasers
because I would always wear heels to church and again my mom had a very large shoe collection
that I wish I could have inherited but my feet are bigger than my mother's and she had a lot of
gorgeous pumps and high heels and taught me how to walk in high heels so walking in high heels
doesn't really bother me at all it's a good thing I've done drag before there you go you're already
on your way you request a french made outfit perfect sold I wore hooters outfit once I'm six
seven sorry I'm just picturing a picturing a giant ass dude in a hooters outfit
high heels aren't that bad high heels for church what kind of church was that
that was just a church my mom made sure I dressed well I have I could probably post a picture of
like me the heels I would wear in one of the outfit wait where is my where's my phone it's
freaking on my phone stands for hold on I want to peek do I have any nope that's my butt um
do I have any of me going to church no that's me with church friends not in my church where
oh this is one but it's with a group of people
these were wedges I was wearing a nice yellow dress my hair looks horrendous though this was
back in 2016 um do I have any more I know I have more than that I'll ask my mommy mommy do you have
any pictures of me at church oh here's the one I was looking for
why do I look like such a dingus
okay but none of them is showing the shoes that I'm wearing
oh this picture of me my parents is so I look so muscular what the hell
holy crap why do I look so swole
damn this is a good picture of me my eyebrows are on fleek holy shit my glasses are cute
my nails are nice sorry I'm just admiring myself
I was a muscle mommy when I did jujitsu not anymore I'm just kind of normal size now I'm just here
just living she be the dingus confirmed correct
do do do okay and then we do that and then we do that I'm fixing my headphones
oh well I didn't have good self-esteem when I took those pictures trust me
it's so fun you always like I remember like being really obsessed with the way that I looked in
terms of like my weight and stuff and I look back on like a video of me like dancing and I was a
freaking plank literally I looked freaking like anorexic bro and I'm like why did I think I was fat
because beauty standards and uh photoshop that's why um now I'm just like I don't you know now I
don't worry about that anymore now I wish I could give my younger self a hug and tell her that she
was beautiful as hell rocky horror picture show watch I've actually never seen rocky horror picture
show yeah it's so funny how your mind plays tricks on you mm-hmm
what I wouldn't mind wrestling with the mushroom me you have to ask Azura for that Azura is the muscle
mommy Azura is super swole I can just skip it
did it not save
okay I can click continue
oh what I totally forget what I was doing
oh oh uh oh don't kill the father don't do it how does he not die then
I don't remember don't kill him you motherfucker
oh yeah I remember I got caught up because I didn't want him to die
you like my granny outfit damn he did
yeah do something
what the hell is that why did she just stand there
help help help
why do you stand in the middle of it I can't protect you if you're standing there bro
oh why are you being so cute oh the baby girl
hi
you're a gill fonder I hate the yelling
oh
where are you going
oh oh my god she's gonna kill him
oh I was facing the wrong way whoopsies mortis
lady stop it stop floating around like the wicked witch of the west
what could wish of the weast where are you
oh my god the yelling is so annoying at this point
oh
how am I not dead
is she frozen hello what was that
okay
I I I I I'm a little butterfly
Oh, you know what I just remembered I have an uncrustle wool.
All I read today is two egg, boiled eggs, some cut apples, some grapes, some sliced
salami, some cheese and some crackers, and some pickles.
Oh it's mine, you can't have any.
My heart rate goes up when I eat an uncrustle wool.
Not even a crumb, excuse me, oh mine, oh wait what am I doing, I'm pressing the wrong
buttons, I was pressing S and D, I wasn't, I was pressing the wrong bookies.
Oh am I right, die.
Okay I don't think I'm gonna keep this guy alive, I don't really care anymore, oh I'm
dead, mortis, yeah I don't, I don't really care that much about him anymore.
Where are you going, I really should back up when you yell like that.
I want it, sorry I was looking at chat, I wanted to save Father Garcia but the reason
why I keep dying is because of him so I don't really, I can't do it bros I'm sorry I'm
just not strong enough, I'm not cool enough, I'm not much of a gamer.
Why are you so close?
Oh my god, cuz she goes for him and I can't save his ass, yeah see like I can't, cuz
if she spawns close to him there's really nothing I can do about it.
Oh my god.
Why isn't she dead yet, like this is what I mean.
She just so you know when he's flashing near Garcia I mean she'll attack him, you have
to show her the cross before she does, oh thank you, flashing near Garcia I mean she'll
attack him, okay.
I'll try to see if I know what you mean.
Frick.
Father Garcia why did you walk, have to walk into a line of fire.
Alright let's try this.
Nevermind.
Why are you so close?
Why are you on my footy cheeks?
Oh my god, oh my god she almost fucking walked into me, I'm flashing, oh I was standing right
on top of her.
I know what to do but I like to call it a her, cuz it looks like a girl to me, it looks
like an evil lady, she looks and she screams like an evil lady, oh okay I see what you
mean.
Frickin speed racer over here, I'm still in the wrong way.
She kind of bad though, she kind of a mommy.
Back up, back up, back up, back up, back off my brother.
Back up, oh my god, Jesus fricking Christ, hello, no be gone, be gone thought, oh my
god, what?
I didn't think she was, oh it is a girl, I told you guys it's a girl, somebody said
it was a dude, I told you guys, I fucked, I told you, she's going after, okay thank
you, what hello, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
oh no, fuck, wait, I don't know, yeah it's because I literally don't know how far away,
like I don't know when she's gonna die, I don't, I don't know when she's gonna, like is it three
times I have to do like the whole rigamarole, but it's like I know this is the third phase,
I'm talking about like how many times do I have to try to kill her, third phase, she ran at me,
I did this for like two hours last time I played,
can you, oh my god, stop, oh my god,
oh god, I forget she starts at the top,
oh my god,
why are you just running at me like that,
hail,
oh god, okay, she starts at the top,
okay, no, every time, every time, bro, it's the last phase, I know that's probably the last one,
it's probably the last one, that's what I keep dying on,
I need to move up instead of down perhaps, oh, what, I thought I started with you,
she running, she running,
oh, oh, sorry for your squeaks and that threw me off,
you want a big stretch,
oh, big stretch, let me stretch your legies, oh, big stretch the legies,
sorry it's my cat, oh you're so cute here,
do you want a kiss, oh thank you for the kiss,
all right, all right, all right, let's do this, walking in as I die, like right off the bat,
Mike, hello, yeah, I was like, why am I not, I was just pointed at every one and it wasn't pointing,
oh, bitch,
please, I'm trying to point, I'm pointing down,
okay,
oh, please,
is that a glitch, why does it do that, nope, oh,
bitch,
let's go,
Finally, finally, finally, Fia, thank you for your strength.
Thank you.
Oh, oh, what are you doing?
She really just, like, lovingly placed her paw on my forehead.
Like, my child.
Fia buff is real.
Fia the lifebed companion.
Yeah, little girl.
You get extra scratches.
Blast.
Oh, wait, no.
Hold on, hold on.
Let me, let me fix myself.
Oops.
Oh, I'm in, like, a lot of pain today and I don't know why.
Let me see if I can put this hand dress back on.
Ah, look at me, look at me.
I am the nun now.
I am the nun.
Oh, sorry, my mole flew off my face.
Heroge freckles.
Why does this suck to when I blink?
What is it doing?
Every time I blink, it twitches.
Oh, my, what is that?
Help.
Okay, it doesn't twitch as much now.
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
Whew, whew, unless I move a lot.
Okay.
Why do I keep wheezing when I left?
What the frick is wrong with me?
It's not cute, it's not cute at all.
It's not cute.
It's not it, it's not it, babes.
The habit looks like this.
You're saying my habits stiff?
Your twitch when they blink.
It's in there.
All right.
Would have loved to read that.
Oh, God, I wonder what it said.
It's clavis.
Sorry, that's how I open doors.
Why not?
Wait, can I go into this room then?
Clavis is key.
Well, I figured that out.
I meant like, what does it go to?
John, it's not too late.
Your soul can still be saved.
All is not lost.
Just kidding.
Let me.
John, it is not too late.
Your soul can still be saved.
All is not lost.
Please wait for my next letter.
For now, I have many questions that need answering.
In the meantime, be careful.
I am watching you.
There's still a little bit of hard tune on that.
Lipsies, turn the echo down.
Oh.
But did I really do the right thing?
Forget TikTok voices.
Get these voices on TikTok.
The boys?
Oh, I, I, Omeland has got my son.
The boys, aren't they dead already?
Is this dude following me?
Fun.
I like how it boots up like that.
That's what, um, I'm pretty sure like inscription uses some of the same sound effects.
Chapter three.
What does show needles mean?
Is that Billy Butcher?
I forget that I have to press it twice.
I'm just like, why is it loading?
September 21st, 1986.
What?
Why is everything muffled hello?
Is this your first exorcism?
Yes, sir.
Are you afraid?
I don't know, sir.
That's daddy to you.
I'll give you a word of advice, champ.
Follow my instructions with exactness.
Don't trust me when you may say you're here.
Cause I'm a man, but there's everything good on it.
Looks like his dinglings between his legs.
The rotoscope is just so good.
He's wearing sunglasses.
Good evening.
This is my assistant for the world.
I'm suddenly from the Sorks family.
Shall we begin?
You know, I don't have to bother voice acting.
You guys can read.
Hi, lady.
Oh, I just got a fucking shiver.
Damn.
Why don't you say so?
I guess I'll go first.
No, she's just doing TikTok dances and she doesn't stop.
Hey.
You see that, bro?
Wait, again, the thing with...
She's in the attic and they get brought to the basement.
It's so weird to me.
I still don't get that.
Da, da, da, da, da.
Oh, got anything to say about that, Father Garcia?
Hey, queen.
That's my cat.
He wakes up besides Father Garcia.
John, we don't have much time.
The profane Sabbath is almost upon us.
If they find Nate and Jason, they will perform a ritual on them
to call forth the demon of unspeakable power.
The name of the demon is Malfas.
I'm in the process of discovering their whereabouts.
I will contact you again soon.
We must not let them do to the boys what they did to Amy.
Oh, I forgot I have to go down.
Going down, down, in an early and round.
Why don't I go in the fun room?
I was just walking by it, but go off this.
John, I can't find Nate or Jason Martin in the state foster care system.
It's...wait.
Wait a second.
So you're telling me...
I thought Amy...
I thought Nate and Jason were Amy's younger brothers
because the lady was talking about how she had twins and a baby
and I thought that was their mother, whatever.
It's possible after what happened last year they went to live with relatives.
I will try to find out what I can.
Meanwhile, go investigate the clinic where Amy worked.
We must find the place where they intend to summon Malfas
and disrupt their plans via Condius, Father Garcia.
I can't do a Spanish accent, so if I did, it would just sound bad.
I am right.
Okay.
I want to see the new exorcist movie.
Was that good?
Did anybody see that?
What was it called?
Deliverance?
Have you forgotten already?
Things are never quite as I see.
If you can't discern truth from lies,
you could try remembering what you know to be true.
Press escape or the star button to review your notes, bitch.
Sure, thank you.
What's in the fridge?
Anything outside?
Sorry, I'm trying to jump off the stairs.
I don't like this.
I don't like this one bit.
I think I definitely will have to watch a lore video on this.
Because I love me some lore.
The lore.
It's not the same without MatPat.
It's not the same.
Face is passing, I'm homebound.
There's three endings.
Well, I already know there's a demon ending that I didn't get.
I wanted to become a demon.
I killed those people.
It didn't work out for me, though.
Oh, this is like the kindergarten thing, right?
I can't recall.
Hey.
This ain't no place for a preacher.
I have a way to relax it.
Can I get hit by a car?
I can get hit by a car, guys.
I figured it out.
Did I say Amy on the wall?
Can I?
Yeah, I'm not gonna break in or anything.
Let's say Kaabunga.
Beetlefest.
Beelzefest.
Is that a Beelzebub?
Beelzebub.
Asmodeus.
Calling all metal fans.
Beelzefest.
1987 rocks the hell out of Hartford.
Friday night, 10 p.m. to 2 a.m.
Featuring appearances by
When all is said and done.
Trust no corpse.
The horror is dead.
Basement two.
Return to bondage.
Enter the sheebie.
Among the bloodshed.
Lying still in silence.
Mother of shadow.
And the door to afterbirth.
I would sell tickets.
$3.
The door?
$5.
I can't speak fast like that.
There's a secret boss?
Where's the secret boss?
I want to get the true ending.
You feel watched.
Am I in a hospital?
Hi, Rhonda.
Just a couple of reminders after last week's visit.
Please keep your desk tidy.
Our patients need to feel at ease with their health care
experience.
Remember our sales points.
Clean, quick, courteous.
Do not return any calls from the Department of Health
before notifying me first or leaving a message with Tiffany.
We cannot afford another surprise inspection.
Please do not call me on my direct personal line
if you happen to hear back from Mrs. Martin.
Oh, one more thing.
Keep Jeffrey out of sight.
Remember, Gary loves you.
Oh, sorry.
I thought that was a woman.
Haunted gurneys.
The cop outside is just staring at us?
I don't know if you can see us.
This is like three-body problem.
It's like, remember that you are loved.
Wait, no.
I always get three-body problem in bodies mixed up
because there's literally like three bodies and bodies
and you know what I meant.
Both of those shows are great.
I don't like that there are pictures of fetuses on the floor.
I don't like pixel fetuses.
I don't get to look at them.
Erma, what the shippity?
I don't know what's going on there.
Hello?
Yeah, no fucking shit.
Part of that give me a jump scare.
Stop!
I'm walking past it.
Oh, yes.
Norman Reedus and the funky fetus.
Sorry, I was reading chat so I walked into a wall.
Why do I sound like I'm having a seizure?
Let me push this chair because I'm a smart gal.
Huh?
No, I can't push the chair over.
I thought this is this chair,
so obviously here to be pushed over to the grate.
Well, never mind.
Stop!
Help.
I'm gonna have a baby.
How did they rotoscope that?
What the f-
How am I moving?
I hate that.
Hide?
How the fuck can I hide?
Oh, you can't see me, right?
You can't see me, right?
I can't see me.
Wait, is there loss on the-
Why is there loss on the curtain?
Can I move out?
You can't see me.
Shut up about hiding.
Can I go in here?
You can't see me, right?
Tell me I can't go in there.
Tell me I can't kick the door open.
Speed! I am speed!
I'm strapped to a gurney.
I'd hope so.
Thanks.
I'm stuck.
Are you gonna shoot me? What the hell is that?
Let's go in here. Come on.
Come on, copper.
Never mind.
Let's go upstairs, baby girl.
We're leaving! Wait, where do I go?
Stop!
Wait, what? Hold on.
Wait, actually, the one time.
Okay, weird, but I thought I saw something in the picture.
Like, something gold.
I might have been to spin my cross.
Hey, can you move the chair?
Can you give me a boost, brother?
I like how he says you're coming with me.
Come on, dude. Come on.
There you go. There you go, sugar tits.
Give me a boost.
Give me a fucking boost. Give me a fucking boost.
No? Alright.
Fuck your mother, then. I'm leaving you in this room.
You know what? No, I'm trapping you here.
I'm trapping you here.
Come over here. Come over here. Come over here.
Come over here.
Get over here. Yep, yep, yep.
Perfect. Nope. Perfect.
You're trapped now.
Damn it.
Can we leave?
How the fuck did you get in here, then?
At least you have a gun.
Huh.
Uh, I don't know.
Get cut!
Oh my god.
Don't fucking shoot me, dumbass!
I'm backing myself into a corner.
Hmm.
I'm going to need your crowbar.
Whoa, two choices here.
One is to see you.
One is to play 1k.
One is to clean up this room...
Oh wait no he shows up over here again.
Oh never mind, no he doesn't.
Come on, yeah get him.
Ah I can do it through the wall.
He did.
Life left, I know, left me crosses on the stairs, type of things that let me know she
hates me.
Say it ain't so, I am a priest, oh my god I almost got hit by a car with Gary in it.
Now go back into the clinic.
Interesante, it's a good boss time, it's a good boss.
Do you guys like my song?
All the demons.
What the fuck is this, football, the narrow.
Go back to the gurney and get on it.
Why would I get on the gurney, baby.
Alright, let's catch a ride.
What, get back to the table and back on the door?
Get in the gurney, okay so I guess I literally have to get on that gurney.
Oh my god, it's choked on my spit, oh yes.
Join us, I'm trying my best here.
No, now what do I do, I'm just doing a little jig on here, I gotta wait a bit, hello.
Let me in, let me in.
What the hell, zoom.
Why do I strap myself back to it?
Oh, I think I see what the problem is doctor, that man does not have a face.
Oh, he about to hit the gritty.
Alright.
Oh, it just fucking falls out of there, what is that noise?
Who the fuck are you, I'm not gonna walk on that, fuck that.
Hey, what's up queen?
Please don't wake the baby.
Oh, fuck, oh, yeah?
Little human being, John's so real for that, I'm leaving now.
Hi I'm baby, great, another boss battle, what is that?
I'm fighting dead babies, I hate that immensely, don't touch my feet, don't touch my feet,
okay, they're getting a little faster, I wonder where you got all the baby noises
from, I'm trying to turn around, please don't let me die from babies, ooh two fur, I got
me a two fur, they look like fish, not gonna lie to you, they look like fish, am I supposed
to go after her, ah, help, it's actually better to get them in a group, alright, well,
babies, babies, it's a lot of dead babies, can you guys like hold up for like a quick
second, trying to kill your like summoning mother, not the fish, the fish are coming
for me, okay let me try to get them all together again, it's actually way better when they're
coming, come on, this is harder than it looks, so many dead babies, oh my god this one just
popped out, maaaam, they're biting at my ankles, I might get myself cornered, nope I'm fine,
oh, what, hello, I'm not quite sure what's happening there, she's using the baby shields,
oh what's that, what is that, nope, no I'm good, I'm so good with that, I might die, oh no,
too many fucking babies,
oh no, no, oh man, this is so hard, are you kidding me,
revenge of the Tamagotchi, hi Vio, hi you little girl,
oh my god, fuck bro, I thought I had more time,
is it, what, can I just stand right on her,
the hell,
nope, nope, nope, not you dumb freaking baby,
okay they don't kill you right away, they just slow you down, sorry I'm so quiet because I'm just
setting babies on fire,
no that one's gonna kill me,
this is so hard,
yep
Yippee.
Corsa, no right, that sounds so familiar.
Catholic Flamin' 1920's number of babies.
Yay!
I'm happy I didn't take a bazillion years like I did with the other one.
Got the note?
Was there a note that I missed it?
I was looking at chat.
Yeah!
Smooth moves, priest.
But the twins are not here.
Carry out the works of your god, wallages yet there for the night, comment.
I can't, I don't have a voice in particular for any of them.
He just dances up the stairs.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
I don't think Gary loves me guys, I think you're lying.
I can't leave.
I wonder what the red dude was then.
There's a bunch of fetus babies around, they're suing his hips.
He got a badonkadonk.
We all know that he has that schlong, you can see the little thing between his legs.
He's swinging, he big dick swinging.
Oh!
Do I leave?
No, I'm not leaving yet.
Cop is also dead, wait, what?
Damn, how far can I go?
Go investigate the police officer, I will do that in a moment.
Okay, that's just going to repeat, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T,
T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T,
T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T, T.
Hey.
I just hold that up.
You tell me I can't take this man's gun.
Oh, I just walked over a crime scene.
There's a sale going on.
There's Gary.
Trying to hit me with his damn car again.
A gun with one bullet.
There was a bird.
I'm gonna wait.
There's that little mouse doing mouse things.
You can see this little tail.
Like I was just the pixel moving.
Can I, okay.
I was like, hello?
Be alza, baby.
Sorry, that was, I got an achievement.
Oh.
I'm breaking the seal on your womb.
Am I supposed to?
Well, I'm, I'm.
Sorry, the book just appeared.
She looks like a guy.
She looks hateful.
Old you really.
Sorry after the book is flying out of my hands.
She looked really ugly.
She looked with her leg between the tables.
You know, she was singing.
I don't know why the demon take land so much
Enomin Jesucristi ki venturas adjudicaer vivos et mortuas
You really want to what be down here?
Move get the get out leave
Well
Am I supposed to lead them away? Oh, I am
Do you guys not know how to go around your own house apparently I don't like how you guys are walking
I don't like how your feet are different than mine. What's up with that? Why do you guys have feet and I don't?
Stay the fuck upstairs
It's not anyways by
It's something else is a demon
Father already fucking dead
Cuz
I
Damn my whoa, sorry, I'm going Super Saiyan priest
Oh not that music
I
Waking up from a lot of dreams two days is for the profane Sabbath
There's so many notes at my door
Actually, you know what I'm gonna do. I'm gonna end it here. I've seen toys today. I'm gonna go
Do my mods just not exist anymore, but they just not here
All right, I'm just gonna whatever um
But uh, yeah, I'll see you guys later
Let me find someone to read
I'll miss you all I'll see you guys tomorrow for the collab. It's gonna be super fun and giggly
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep. Actually, I want to check Merrow super quick. See if you guys said anything before I get off
Nope. Okay, cool. Just want to make sure. And then I think I had some donos from the
ASMR stream that I missed. Oh, thank you anonymous for the $48 tip. That was crazy. Thank you, Jesus.
His name isn't Jesus.
All right, that was... Yeah, I missed like one random tip.
You're drawing my ASMR stream. Very kind. Thank you.
People are so sweet. I don't deserve it.
But maybe they're paying for the bill that I ran out on in the ASMR roleplay.
They're like, here's... They're like, I'll just leave the money here.
I thought that was pretty funny. I was like, how could I end the stream? And I'm like,
I mean, I've been listening to Turkey Tom's video and Daniel Larson.
And this is a man who's deeply disturbed, mentally ill.
Man, and he just constantly dines and dashes. So I'm like, yeah, let's do that.
There's three hour commentary on it. I've just been like, what?
But it's interesting because I used to work with people like that. And I'm just like,
this is someone who doesn't get the help that they need. It's very sad.
But I hope you guys like the ASMR today. I hope you guys liked the
faith. We're probably going to finish faith next time I play this. And then, yeah, I'm going to go
write a script and then try to record it. Or I'm just going to try to write a lot of scripts
and then try to record them. But yeah, say bye, Fiya. Bye. Oh, she's giving you guys kisses. You can't see.
Yeah. She's sending licks your way. Part three is pretty long. It might be a two-parter.
But yeah, you might get some ASMR guerrilla rambles from time to time now that I feel a lot more
confident with my, what's it called? Microphone settings. But yeah, I miss you guys. I'm going to
miss you guys. I feel like I'm leaving. Like I'm gone for two days, but it's literally going to be
like a couple hours. I'll see you guys tomorrow in a couple hours. But it's not now. I'm so used to
being hyperparas to the outside and just spam talking all the time. But I keep getting myself
in trouble and cause a mess when I'm going to chill out. But know that I love you when I miss you.
A couple hours is too long. Maybe I'll do a space note. I have to focus. I have to focus.
I have to lock in. I have to lock in and I have to focus.
Emmy just sent me part one. Oh boy. I have to listen to that. I almost started playing it on
stream. Let me not do that. You guys are going to like it. Have fun. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. I hope you have a good night. I love you mom. I love you mom. Bye. Wait, I didn't find
someone to read. Hold on. Wait. We're not leaving it. Oh, that's you. That's you. That's you.
Okay. We got a lot. We got a couple go at least that I could rate.
I want to rate someone I haven't rated before.
Oh no. But I'm too nervous to rate that person.
Find someone to rate who's going to keep streaming.
I want to rate Kai. They just started.
They're playing Genshin. But I'm nervous.
I like Kai. Kai is cool. Do you see what happened yesterday? What happened yesterday?
What do you mean? Did something happen after I rated yesterday? I rated. I said hi.
And then I ran away because I got too embarrassed and scared to talk. And then they were doing a
clap. So I can do it. She ended.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you for the tap and on. Thank you for the 22, 22.
Is that Jesus again? It's Hessus. Jesus Christ. It keeps happening. I just have bad luck with
raids. Watch her just like her stream crash. Just because of me.
Okay. We're going to rate Kai and I'm scared. And you can just say she be raid. That's okay.
All right.
I'm going to go have a panic attack.
I accidentally closed the tab.
Please don't stop streaming raid. I got so anxious. I closed the tab.
Okay.
All right. We're doing it. We're going to raid. And it's going to be not fine.
Anxiety. No, don't say anxiety raid. Please don't do that. Okay. I care about you guys a lot.
I love you. Goodbye.